let's go next to uh there's just so many
people who want to get on here it's very
very interesting
um why don't we go to let's go to
adam from dubai adam from dubai what's
going on
hey what's good david how you doing
pretty good
i've been a fan of the show for a while
what's uh what's it like in dubai right
now
um pretty hot it's getting a lot better
but uh just dealing with this whole
covet thing
yeah all right well what can i do for
you today
yeah i like i i don't know if a lot of
americans know like how much the
election
impacts this part of the world but um
like we tend to keep up with it a lot
and like i'm just wondering like given
because to me like it seems like it's a
clear choice between biden and trump
but there's still like a lot of both
sizes that i still see
yeah especially like in progressive uh
circles
so i'm just wondering like what the
rationale behind that is
there's a there's a bunch of different
things going on there's not one answer
so you certainly have people
who so in terms of undecideds the
typical
undecided is center-right
relatively young and not paying
attention very closely so most of the
undecideds or people that could go
either way are not people that are on
the left that's important to understand
among those who are on the left and are
unsure
you have a contingent that just doesn't
like joe biden that that would be just a
very specific thing like okay trump
aside i don't like biden so i'm not
going to vote for biden
you have the both sides ists who say
if it's not a quote true progressive i
don't care whether it's trump or biden
we saw in 2016 how that failed us trump
now has had two and
potential potentially will get a third
supreme court pick so you have that
contingent
um you have people who uh would be open
to vote
open to voting for joe biden but want to
feel as as though joe biden
came and got their vote and earned their
vote and for me
you know i don't need that i just look
at biden's policy and i see
oh biden's policy is better i'll vote
for biden and it's sort of that simple
so you've got a lot of different
things on the left going on at once but
most people are going to vote for biden
that's the reality
some of these anti-biden left-wing
enclaves
they're very loud online but most people
realize what's going on
sure uh like i mean i'm not concerned
about
like individuals you know write a post
or whatever but
like seeing online commentators like
that i won't name
uh on on the left uh essentially still
stick to their guns on this
and when you say stick to their guns
what are their guns just that biden's
bad and you shouldn't vote for him
yeah like so saying that no one won the
debate and saying that
hey like you know the american people
still uh like
will lose no matter who wins like trying
to muddy the waters
and a clear choice yeah and that sounds
irresponsible to me because
if there's a better choice you go with
the better choice you know it's sort of
like
if you really believe that we're talking
about two bad choices
isn't there a moral responsibility to
act in the way that that
pushes the less bad choice like if you
say to me
would you rather have a sinus infection
or covid and maybe the covid gets really
serious
i'm not looking for either but given the
choice i would say give me the sinus
infection you know
sure yeah and and also like i don't
understand the uh
uh like i i don't feel like we have the
luxury to play those games of like
oh i want to bite indicator to me or i
want him to do such and such
right given how terrible the situation
really is
i completely agree with you all right
cool
all right thanks david all right adam
from dubai great to hear from you there
there he is adam from dubai i want to
take a second to tell you about one of
our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are very
reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping
is free on orders over a hundred and
fifty dollars you can get there by going
to davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david